let's talk about the ramifications of
this fake evidence
the the prosecution won a major victory
when they were able to get the judge to
instruct the jury on provocation
if you believe that cal rittenhouse
provoked the attack then he must have
exhausted all means of retreat otherwise
it is not self-defense i think something
that effect
and
if they didn't have this video footage
with that argument about him pointing
the weapon there would have been no prop
provocation instruction the jury would
have been told he was attacked if you
believe he acted in self defense or quit
here's what we got from newsmax and i
don't know if this is true but this is
newsmax reporting
a smack source reports they overheard
kyle reddenhouse's attorney saying that
he believed the jury is at a six six
split mike carter reports from the
courthouse in kenosha
it could be a hung jury
we've already heard rumors uh jack
pasobic said he had a source claiming
that there were two holdouts that that
uh he said you know 10 people were in
agreement two were holding out we that
could mean that 10 wanted to convict i
mean the two didn't it could mean that
10 wanted to acquit and two didn't we
don't know for sure
but one thing that's interesting is that
the defense made a verbal motion for
mistrial
straight up mistrial
that would mean written house would be
tried again
we mentioned this the other day
cernovich said it's it's an advantage
for the for the defense they'll get to
do this whole thing over knowing exactly
what the state has and
here's what people have missed
if everything i said about krauss and
the manipulation of this evidence is
true it will get thrown out and the
state will have no opportunity to
present that further more if krause did
do something untoward he could get in
serious trouble and the case may
actually
something beyond a retrial may happen if
it turns out that they did something
malicious it could actually it might not
be with prejudice but it may actually
create a political pressure where they
can't retry kyle rittenhouse so
if we're looking at a hung jury
and the defense is like okay we're gonna
do we're gonna get a do-over let's add a
verbal motion for mistrial what people
need to know is the judge has both
motions to consider the judge could rule
either way it's just more
options for the defense
i keep thinking about how the how the
jurors are coming in on a bus where they
can't see anything but they hear
screaming people screaming at them they
the people outside know who it's like if
you're led into a courthouse blindfolded
and people all around you are screaming
at you as you're walking in how
horrifying and mind-twisting that would
be and then to have to
to decide the fate of of basically those
the people outside as well the the
people that are screaming at you
you're
that well someone's decision's gonna
weigh on if i rule this way will there
be consequences and other people hurt
because of the way i roll so that's also
another aspect that we have to consider
here when we have these kind of
egregious cases of people trying to make
photos of them people following them the
people screaming outside of them so so
there's a lot to play into this but what
did the judge rule because i know the
defense said mistrial with prejudice
then then they reached for mistrial
without prejudice
what was his kind of understanding of
this did he did he decide on it or did
he say i'm going to wait until this
comes out the first time uh the defense
made a verbal motion for mistrial with
prejudice
the judge said i'll take it under
advisement and then he basically was
like if there's one more violation you
guys watch yourself
they made a formal the filing for
emotion uh mishra with prejudice
we didn't hear him we didn't hear
anything about that from the judge the
verbal motion for mistrial the judge
basically said
i'm going to wait till the jury comes
back with a verdict and we'll see excuse
me hiccups
i'm so i'm really curious here like
maybe like anyone's opinion on like
what's what's the impact gonna be is is
there any way that this can go where the
impact of what's happening in kenosha
would be different do you think it's
it's just gonna escalate no matter what
yep well you got the mainstream media
putting fuel on the fire you got the
mainstream media screaming going crazy
trying to make this a race issue and
it's not you got the mainstream media
sorry corporate media as as malice would
call them literally fanning the flames
here in every instant just like they did
um last summer yeah so with that
happening i mean people were like
guaranteeing that something was going to
happen we don't know exactly but the
conditions that created previous civil
unrest are there for this current period
now there there's different times we're
not going through the summer the summer
is usually the hot period where there is
a lot of civil unrest but there are
memes going around showing ron paul at
the federal reserve disguising it with a
nike store saying that uh this is a meme
this is not a real image but it's a meme
saying that he hopes that during rioting
season people will target the federal
reserve and think i love it
but but so so there's a right wasn't
there a babylon b article about that or
something like i believe so
oh no what have the writers done i've
seen the meme and i have to share the
meme uh
because it hit home to what's really
going on here
but but who knows what's going to happen
here the conditions are there we can
only hope and do our best to try to
provide a reasonable side of the story
to try to provide some kind of
explanation that will decrease the risk
of violence and
escalation but the escalation has been
there it's significant and i think it's
only going to get even more significant
the judge
should have declared a mistrial with
prejudice immediately
because
what people have been saying and what
the judge is saying is you know he's
going to wait for the verdict if it's a
not guilty verdict then the rulings are
irrelevant
the problem is
then the j then the prosecution goes we
got away with it
we tried our best we cheated to our
hearts content but we didn't win
that means they could do it again
now there's also the potential warning
that if a guilty verdict you know issue
if a guilty verdict does come in the
judge could be like mistrial with
prejudice blame this blame the
prosecutors
well yeah there's a story
there's definitely a story no matter
which way this swings there's a story to
escalate it i feel i think it was
katherine austin fitz she did some
research on the the 2020 riots alone and
she said
i may get the numbers wrong but 35 out
of 37 of the the main parts of the
damage done to infrastructure was done
right around maybe within a quarter or a
half mile of a central bank
and her whole theory like i mean again
this is just her theory saying that like
you know this is exactly where they're
gonna build up the smart grid
you know so i don't know i'm not gonna
press on that one but i i love when i
hear people outside the box
investigation being like i'm just going
to look at what else there is around all
these spots that seem to be
unnecessarily damaged what is the smart
grid exactly well a smart
so you know the internet of things it's
part of their 2030 plan for all major
urban cities to be digitized and to be
run through a kind of uh sorry i cut you
off that but to be run through a kind of
centralized grid
it's totally centralized and it's it's
the device you know over in china
i think robert spalding was talking
about this in his uh i forget what book
stealth wars or something like that but
he was saying like over in china
there's not even the need for the device
anymore because there's so many cameras
and microphones um that the very next
step is you walk out your door and you
say uber it acknowledges who you are by
your voice or where you're standing and
the camera and it comes by and picks you
up and you're in the device so the smart
grid is definitely what what luke was
saying about it's it's creating the
internet of things everywhere and mind
you smart dust was being talked about in
2000 going into pavement and it's
already there in denver
that's a big that's a big rabbit hole
but also in china if you jaywalk they
take a photo of you they don't you don't
need to show your identification you
don't need to report to anyone they take
a photo of you and a fine automatically
is deducted from your bank account and
you get a notification on your phone
you've been you've been punished for
jaywalking on this street and we took
this money out of your bank account
that's the smart grid smart dust you're
taking us down the rabbit hole i like
this bed finally we're getting we're
getting started here i like this
this is some uh this is down the rabbit
hole stuff that i think we need to go
down into allison i'll just say this
allison mcdowell you know is talking
about um where we're moving is total
gamification um by 6g everyone will have
uh like up to 12 digital twins so
avatars
and um all connected to this thing
called the sentient world simulation
which is a if you've seen the last
season of west world it's basically a
digital mirror of this world but in real
time and i forget what their prediction
was but when it gets to minority report
level where it can start predicting
people's actions what groups you'll end
up in what stores you'll end up at when
why where those steps this is the
digitization of everything this is mark
zuckerberg's metaverse but in real life
but but and this is how they're going to
do it you're going to be in the pod
eating the bugs living in the society
where they will track trace and database
every aspect of your existence to
the nano particle of smart intelligent
dust and and and microchip particles
that will be in charge of controlling
every aspect of your human existence so
colonization all the way down to our
biology just look up
international barcode of life and see
who some of the main donors to that
thank you mr gates yeah mr bill gates i
was just gonna say gates gates
so hold on so this is this is a big
segway right we're talking about a
potential hung jury in a criminal trial
and now we're talking about that
coincidence sorry i just got off i went
up you guys you guys just like blasted
off yeah
but but i have a question i mean
are you saying that you think that the
riots and all the destruction we've seen
is somehow tied to
i'll just put it simply i mean i think
it's fair to say an attempt to gain more
control politically over people's lives
and i think if you walk back from the
smart dust stuff you know there's
something that's kind of freaky for
people to understand and you said
something like you know why is the
police stand down and allow the riots
why is it that the media promotes them
why did kamala harris fundraise for them
the violence scares people and triggers
a response where they say give us more
money to keep you safe
yeah you know like i'm just theorizing
here um i've i've been looking into this
i think last time we talked about agenda
20 uh 2020 gender 2030 and everything
like that i personally feel like you've
talked about davos you've talked about
world economic forum the whole idea is
moving from stakeholder capitalism to
shareholders or maybe it's the other way
shareholder capitalism to stakeholder
capitalism you need an excuse to
radically
not just homogenize world economies and
bring them all together under one but
you need an excuse a public facing
excuse so to me and this is yet again
another thing that um catherine austin
fitz says is like invisible threats are
great you can like call terrorism for
one and you can't tell who's the
terrorist you know it could be anyone it
could be your neighbor be very
suspicious of your neighbors type of
thing the um covet
the well exactly and so the idea about
it is like again this is just a theory
but like i definitely feel that davos
wants to succeed in this great reset and
so the forward facing like what's the
excuse how do we tell the the future
generations why this whole thing went
down
um i'm not saying that like what's
happening right now is fake and i'm not
saying that anything along those lines
but opportunizing the never let a good
crisis go to waste exactly and so to me
i absolutely feel that this needs to be
spun
in this direction and and i'll just take
it back to what i said about the kyle
rittenhouse case and why it's so iconic
is because it's a it's
a man a 17 year old with a rifle
at
in front of small businesses which are
being i mean i think i saw a woman today
saying i i run a shop in kenosha 50
of shops have been shut down small
businesses shut down they never reopened
a lot of them are moving out of the area
there's something happening if you if
you like to call it all a coincidence
that's fine i i personally don't mind
taking several leaps of faith in order
to at least take
think of what it could be what could be
happening because you'll never get the
full story the the uh
you know i don't i don't like the big
conspiracy stuff i think it gets too
grandiose and it makes too many
assumptions and i think there's actually
some evidence to suggest this is
definition never let a good crisis go to
waste and that is when the covet stuff
first started you were not allowed to
talk about it on social media it was the
craziest thing when the first news came
out of wuhan of the weird stuff i made
some videos on youtube youtube didn't
notice didn't care then there was this
period where they were like you cannot
talk about this you'll be demonetized
and they're exerting pressure on
channels that were actually saying hey
there's an outbreak i think initially
that the the establishment was like this
is panic stuff we don't want anyone
talking about this and then once it hit
and and the establishment politicians
are like wait wait wait wait wait wait
we can use this we can use the crisis
15 days becomes two years
then all of a sudden youtube's like
actually we're gonna allow you to start
talking about it and then truth be told
when the more and more videos are
popping up about it this the fear
spreads and it allows a lot more uh
corrupt politicians and powerful ceos
big pharma corporations to be like now's
our chance to use fear to gain power
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you